I first want to go outside the White
House to chief White House correspondent
John Roberts 3 p.m. the world will be
watching
yeah and Harris there's just so many
moving parts to this story today and so
much has happened in just the past half
hour the president has said that he will
have a press conference at 3 o'clock
this afternoon Fox News has been told
that the president is likely to declare
a national state of emergency or
national emergency under what's known as
the Stafford act of 1988 what this does
is it unlocks FEMA disaster funds in the
same way award if there was a massive
hurricane or a big earthquake or some
other natural disaster here in the
United States so that will put into
force the full weight of the funding of
the federal government for disaster
relief to do all kinds of things that
the president may designate as a result
of this now at another story that seems
to change back and forth literally
minute to minute we were told just
recently on America's newsroom by
Eduardo bol sanera who is the son of the
Brazilian president higher bolsa narrow
that his father has tested negative for
coronavirus that was about an hour after
Anwar Doble sanera had told Fox News as
for his father the president had tested
positive for coronavirus so what the
real status of that is we don't know but
we do know that the president was in
proximity to bowls an hour for a number
of hours on Saturday night last Saturday
night at mar-a-lago so does that now
have implications as to whether or not
President Trump should get tested and we
found out in the last half-hour that
Francis Suarez the mayor of Miami who
was in close contact with Boston arrow
and his team over last weekend has now
himself tested positive for coronavirus
on the subject of testing that remains a
real problem here more currently
existing tests are going out some four
million are supposed to be out there in
the communities by the end of the week
maybe the end of the weekend also Health
and Human Services is giving more than a
million dollars to two companies that
are developing rapid diagnostic tests
for corona virus the two tests may be
able to detect whether a person has the
virus within an hour White House and
Democrats still working to hammer out a
financial package to help expand testing
also expand medical
paid medical leave and unemployment
insurance but the White House is still
pushing for a payroll tax cut getting
rid of that 12.4% employee and employer
paid tax for Social Security until the
end of the year here's what the Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin said about it
earlier today there the president's very
interested in the payroll tax cut
because it's a giant stimulus we're
working with Congress on that if
Congress wants to do the stimulus in a
different format we'll consider that but
the president wants to put money in the
economy for hardworking Americans who
are impacted by this now it's where we
are overall in this crisis minuchin said
this morning we're in the second inning
that a lot more is going to be needed
including possible financial help of
some sort for the airlines of the united
states which are being impacted so
heavily by this and really Aris that's
only the beginning when you look at the
overall trickle-down effect of what's
happening in the economy from the
coronavirus and that's all just in the
last hour you know I feel like we should
come back to you every five seconds
become overly much to bring us you know
what thank you for the great work as
always my friend